[Music]
on this Sunday night the new narrative
being pushed by the Russian president
Putin's new rhetoric and warning to the
Russian people as Fierce fighting
escalates on the first anniversary of
Russia's Invasion it's a major goal with
his speech was to convince a domestic
audience that he was justified in his
war against Ukraine plus witnesses to
war in a lot of ways it's harder because
the grief and the horror of what's been
happening there has just been building
how our course respondents and crew
members are reflecting after what they
saw on the ground in Ukraine
from she session to chiccovery why women
are flooding into the workforce
honoring acting icon Gordon Pinson
finding the center of your story The
Beating Heart of it that's what makes a
reporter looking back at the Canadian
Pioneers prolific seven decades on the
big screen
global national with Fara Nasser
yeah good evening and thank you for
joining us as Russian forces ramp up the
offensive one year since the start of
the war the Russian president is also
ramping up his rhetoric suggesting the
West wants to completely dismantle
Russia we're going to get to his
comments in a moment but first we want
to begin tonight in eastern Ukraine and
in the Strategic city of bakmut a place
Russian forces have been trying to
encircle for months now Russia is
claiming to have captured a key Village
near the city as an anniversary present
but the reality on the ground might be a
different story
bakbut has seen some of the fiercest
fighting since the War Began this new
drone video you're watching was
published today by Russian State media
it shows a scene of total devastation
but according to Kiev Ukraine is still
in control of the Strategic City and it
says that Russia's new offensive has so
far been unsuccessful
here's what we know to be true the
fighting in and around has been
Relentless for each inch of territory
and the casualties high on both sides
and as the war enters its second year
Putin has a new message for the Russian
people filled with specific accusations
against the West Redmond Shannon has our
top story tonight
the front lines in the donbass an almost
lunar landscape scarred by War in this
nearby coal mining town Ukrainian troops
defend what's left and who's left
it's nine days since my sister died says
this woman Emilia is one of the
russian-speaking ukrainians that
Vladimir Putin claims to be attempting
to liberate
in an interview on Russian State tv
Putin again lashed out at the West for
supporting Ukraine he says part of the
reason he recently suspended his
country's participation in the new start
nuclear treaty with the United States
was because of NATO's combined nuclear
capabilities referencing the nuclear
weapons held by France and the UK his
major goal with this speech was to
convince a domestic audience that he was
justified in his war against Ukraine
Putin claims the West one wants to see
his country broken up and dismantled if
Russia loses the war suggesting to
Russians their future as a distinct
Sovereign people would be threatened
there have been some Western analysts
recently worrying about what might
happen if Russia loses this war
disastrously could the country break up
and Putin seized on that comment as
evidence that that was actually
Washington's secret goal U.S President
Joe Biden stated just the opposite this
past week the United States nations of
Europe do not seek to control or destroy
Russia Saudi Arabia's foreign minister
visited key Sunday Saudi leadership says
it wants to see a diplomatic resolution
to the fighting but ukrainians will
remind Outsiders that for them this war
is now entering its 10th year Sunday is
Ukraine's annual day of resistance to
the occupation of Crimea marking
Russia's annexation of the peninsula in
2014. Redmond Shannon Global News London
in the first days of last year's
Invasion the Ukrainian city of Hassan
fell the russian-speaking Ukrainian city
was the only Regional Capital to be
captured by Moscow but in November the
Ukrainian military took the city back
and that was thanks in part to an
underground resistance that was led by
ordinary civilians Jeff Semple tells
that story from her son
Russia's invasion of Ukraine isn't going
as planned but capturing her son was
perhaps the kremlin's most significant
victory
on March 2nd the Russian military took
control of the southern city and
Vladimir Putin claimed it would remain
part of Russia forever but Lilia
alexandrova had other plans
the stay-at-home mother of three doesn't
look like your stereotypical resistance
leader but that may have helped her
evade detection Russian Vehicles
patrolled the street outside her
apartment but after dark she would sneak
out armed with a can of spray paint
there you go Ukrainian flag
alexandrova secretly painted Ukrainian
flags all around her Russian occupied
neighborhood
my hands were shaking and my heart was
pounding I was so nervous she says but I
knew that God would protect us because I
was doing the right thing when the
Russians covered up her work she would
make her Mark again and again and again
you're very brave
and courage can be contagious before
long she started seeing markings from
others one of the most common symbols a
yellow ribbon
the yellow ribbon United us and showed
that we were against the Russians and
that we were waiting for the Armed
Forces of Ukraine to liberate our city
she says but what began as a silent
largely symbolic protest quickly evolved
into a full-blown underground resistance
yellow ribbon it's a
biggest movement Alex whose identity
we're protecting is an I.T worker turned
civil resistance leader in the first
weeks of the occupation he says they
organized secret meetings and even
anti-russian protests
thank you
provoking a fierce Crackdown from the
Russian occupiers one protester a woman
in her 70s was killed other activists
were arrested Alex says their
whereabouts are still unknown
we showed the Russians that the
Ukrainian people are against them he
says and the way the Russians responded
showed us that they were afraid
this activist in Odessa a few hours West
organized secret evacuations to get
women and children out of her son their
buses forced to cross dozens of Russian
checkpoints it was real nightmare
because any any time they could stop you
they could rob you and they could you
they could send you back we were lucky
that they didn't check out thoroughly
and they just let us through but
eventually he says the Russians
confiscated some of their buses while
another was hit by shelling and after
that all our creation stopped
meanwhile as Russia was holding sham
referendums on annexation in her son and
other occupied territories yellow ribbon
members were secretly sending
information about Russian activities and
positions to the Ukrainian military
I collected as much information and
photos as possible piece by piece and
then sent them the coordinates
alexandrova says then in November after
eight months under occupation the day
she'd been praying for finally came
her son was liberated the Russians
retreating a few kilometers across the
river sparking celebrations in the
streets and the yellow ribbon movement
isn't done yet it now counts more than 4
000 members applying hard learned
lessons to other occupied territories in
Ukraine hoping for a similar outcome
the Russians don't belong here she says
her son is Ukraine
Jeff's Global News her son
in the 12 months since the War Began in
Ukraine the Russian military has
suffered setback after setback and the
same impact was expected for the Russian
economy Western sanctions were supposed
to bring the country to its knees but
within weeks as Eric Sorensen reports
the Russian economy started to rebound
despite being hit hard by Western
isolation
[Music]
the muscovitch is back this was a
Renault Factory till last year but like
so many Western companies the French
automaker pulled up Stakes over the
Russian invasion of Ukraine so Russia
nationalized the plant and it now
produces the moscovitch a brand from the
old Soviet days
some thought everything would collapse
said President Vladimir Putin this month
nothing is falling apart our domestic
manufacturers now have opportunities
hardship was expected to come from
Global sanctions designed to punish
Russia is adopted
the United Nations voted this week once
more overwhelmingly to denounce The
Invasion but just how isolated has the
war left Russia like the U.N vote last
year 141 countries demanded Russia
withdraw from Ukraine only seven
including Russia voted against but there
were also more than 30 abstentions many
African countries plus India and China
those two countries with over 35 percent
of the world's population have not
shunned Russia Russian oil exports to
China soared to 2 million barrels a day
last month and to India 1.4 million
barrels a day a record high whether
selling energy to China and India or
buying military drones from Iran or
artillery shells from North Korea Russia
can still find Partners to help both its
economy and its military
President Putin met with a top Chinese
official this week a message to the
world that Russia has friends China is
building new pipelines to transport
Russian gas from Siberia and Putin is
strengthening relationships with the
so-called Global South you can think of
the use of sanctions as being perhaps
weakening Russia in a very long term but
in terms of altering Behavior right now
no it's not going to have any impact
back at home old Russian Brands like
Kama bicycles are having a Revival
I used to write a comma says Tatiana I
feel positive for our producers most
Russians says one moscow-based pollster
are adapting to a more rustified economy
they don't think about the direct
influence of the sanctions or us we are
we are strong and we can stand
everything the moskovich wasn't very
popular back in the old Soviet days but
in a time of economic sanctions
consumers have no choice but to consider
Russian brands that they once turned
away from Eric Sorensen Global News
the chiccovery is here coming up how
women are leading Canada
's recovery
it's easy to remember how the covid-19
pandemic greatly impacted the economy
shuttering businesses and affecting jobs
yet these days the number of women in
the workforce has never been higher and
it's leading to an economic rebound some
are even calling a she-covery and
gaviela explains
throwing an ax instead of throwing in
the towel Melissa herod's business is
open 365 days a year and this mom is
busy and it's a constant juggling really
uh I think that's probably a pretty
similar situation for most parents she
and her partner make it work both of us
are capable of making the meals and
getting the kids ready for school and
getting the kids to school and putting
them to bed these days business is
thriving but back in 2021 lockdowns and
school closures were constant source of
stress she like many women had to do
double duty many forced out of their
jobs either because their industry was
negatively impacted or because the
demands of home and work became too much
we saw three times more unemployed women
than we saw before the pandemic there
were less women participating in the
labor force today things are different
according to statistics Canada the
employment rate of women in their Prime
working years has hit record highs doing
the heaviest lift in fact women are now
leading the recovery a trend known known
as a she-covery but the burden of
household tasks elder care and child
minding still disproportionately falls
on women experts say the affordable
child care deals Ottawa has Inked with
provinces can help more women get into
and stay in the workforce the
affordability piece has been a challenge
for many women it's it's a reason why
many of them choose to stay at home
um well they don't feel that they have a
choice and even if they can't afford it
there aren't enough spots so this is a
big step forward employers can do their
part to keep women in the labor pool
flexible work is a double-edged sword
but steps need to be taken to ensure
flexible Arrangements don't penalize
women's careers in the long run
sometimes these flexible work policies
are seen as an accommodation
specifically for women and specifically
for mothers keeping women and working
parents on the job is an economic
necessity now and in the future we need
as much woman as we can on the workforce
especially if you tie in the fact that
um aging population usually need a bit
more services and and service Industries
as you know rely heavily on women
employment a sustainable economic
recovery is a sheet covery and gaviola
Global News Toronto
ahead behind the scenes covering a war
one year into Russia's invasion of
Ukraine our correspondents pulled back
the curtain on what it felt like to be
on the ground
since the beginning of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine global news correspondents
and photojournalists have been traveling
to the region to bring you the stories
of the people forever changed by the war
their job has been to document history
but of course they are human too so on
this one year anniversary of the
conflict we asked them to share some of
the experiences that may not have made
it on the news
thank you
once you've done it once or twice you
know what to expect but in a lot of ways
it's it's harder because
um you know the grief and the horror of
what's been happening there has just
been building for a year
for a few days we were stuck in Poland
trying to get into leviv Ukraine
and I just remember the bus load and
busload and busload of people
it was hard not to be struck by these
people who were moving out of danger
going somewhere they just literally
didn't know where
it was just Mother after Mother with
their kids and you're just like
these kids likely won't do their father
again and she won't see her husband
I remember the platform of the of the
train station being so packed with
people it was difficult to move we found
a woman and talked to her and she had
some a couple kids with her
she was trying to get onto the train and
it was just packed she was able to sit
by a window and look at her husband and
and kind of give the goodbyes and the
hands up on the window and it was it was
heartbreaking I tried not to let these
stories affect me too much but this one
did it was it was hard to watch and it
wasn't until the train left that it hit
me and I I broke down and cried it was
uh and that doesn't happen very often
for me so it was it was quite an
experience
one of the interesting things was to see
these refugees moving from leviv from
Western Ukraine into Poland
the biggest processing center they had
for all the refugees
out of nowhere we hear this piano and I
was figuring it was over the loudspeaker
but it was actually a guy that would
put a piano in the back of a truck
once the war started he drove right to
the border to entertain the refugees and
it was a
quite phenomenal
people would be standing with signs
trying to bring people into their
apartments and things like that it that
was a sort of the heartwarming part
everywhere in Ukraine is so different so
as soon as you show up and live people
are in the streets eating at cafes doing
whatever they would do in normal times
you get to Kiev and things are a bit
more unsettled and then you go south to
mikalayev or into harkive and it's it is
a war zone it's actively being shelled
and people are scared
hearing the air raid sirens for the
first time that really again hits you
it's um it's a feeling I've never
experienced before and then
when it was time to actually enter you
know the front line cities
you cross a checkpoint and you have to
put your body armor on
and you can hear the artillery blasts
going off
one of the most sad things to realize is
that people can get used to living under
these kind of conditions
me in the early days of the war There
Was You know the the grief was just
visceral you know people were were
terrified they were angry
after a year of air sirens and missile
strikes and now drone attacks
and being called fascists and Nazis by
Putin I think people are just really
tired
[Music]
next saying goodbye to the actor who
personified Canadian kindness how Gordon
pinsett is being remembered tonight
[Music]
Canadian artists are mourning the loss
of an acting Legend Tonight Gordon
pincent was known for a wide range of
beloved roles through his 70-year career
from voicing the gentle elephant Babar
to his heartbreaking role and away from
her he passed away this weekend at the
age of 92. tonight our microwave looks
back at pinsense Legacy and how he
inspired fellow artists along the way
how do you pick a defining moment from a
career seven decades long to find in the
center of your story The Beating Heart
of it that's what makes a reporter for
the latter stages of Gordon pinson's
storied career it could be his
award-winning turns in the movies like
away from her I'm your husband we've
been married for 45 years Vincent found
the Beating Heart in almost everything
he did and he did it with a Grace that's
rare in the acting World director Sarah
Paulie remembers him for his twinkle of
mischief and a determination to enjoy
the moment and boy did he ever he was a
standout among eccentrics on the red
green show women are attracted to me red
they find me mysterious and who can
forget his Shakespearean performance of
Justin Bieber's teenage autobiography
singers aren't supposed to have dairy
before a show
but we all know I'm a rule breaker
Pizza is just so good born in Grand
Falls Newfoundland pincent found success
in Hollywood with roles in the original
Thomas Crown Affair in Hogan's Heroes
but said it left him stifled creatively
I felt being taken over
quite quite easily in fact and I was
there six years and I can't believe it
was that long so he came home and
extended his talents across stage and
screen for veteran collaborators and
newcomers alike when then fledgling
director Jeremy Lalonde was casting his
film sex after kids he reached out to
pincent on a whim expecting nothing not
only did Pinson star in the film they
became friends it didn't matter that we
had like a crew of maybe 10 people you
know he acted as if we were like the
biggest movie
in the world shooting that time oh my
God not every roll across seven decades
was an award winner but his range this
is a very peculiar situation yes he was
the voice of Babar two was boundless he
simply embraced every role with Grace a
sense of humor and his Newfoundland
charm for someone who you know spent
most of his career here I don't think
there's a bigger icon or Legend than
Gordon Pinson Gordon pincent was 92.
what a career that's global national for
this Sunday night I'm far in Oscar on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you for spending time with us and in
honor of Gordon Vincent we want to leave
you with a view from The Province where
he was born and raised so tonight's your
Canada is the exploits river which runs
through Gordon pinsett's hometown of
Grand Falls Windsor Newfoundland and
Labrador until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
foreign